et pour en parler nous sommes avec
guillaume martin avocat de faouzi
lellouche et priscilla ludo ski bonsoir
guillaume martin merci d'être avec nous
à vos côté stanislas godon délégué
général alliance police bonsoir à vous
également cette liste hasbro non merci
d'être avec nous manifestation de gilet
jaune à on l'a vu qu'ils sont toujours
devant l'assemblée nationale alors où
l'on parle examen précisément au pas les
bonbons du projet doit de sécurité le
même jour sa faim gilet jaune qui
pourrait peut-être prendre cette
coïncidence comme un sacré pied de nez
qu'est ce que vous en pensez 7016 beau
nom mais côté des manifestations dans ce
pays
c'est un droit constitutionnel donc il
n'est pas question de le contester après
mon nous déplorons déjà des jets de
projectiles sur mes collègues sur le
terrain qui n'était venu simplement
encadrer cette manifestation à proximité
de l'assemblée nationale
bon les gilet jaune se sont joints à
cette manifestation contre la loi
sécurité globale c'est leurs
revendications en tout cas nous on
continue à soutenir évidemment cette
proposition de loi
parce que il ya des éléments
intéressants pour notamment sécurisé
pour porter enfin un coup d'arrêt ce
police bashing qui se fait depuis des
mois des années
et puis également certaines dispositions
de la loi qui sont tout aussi protecteur
d'ailleurs pour les citoyens alors on a
vu un
cette loi certes un gilet jaune
finalement s'en sentent responsables
puisque on rappelle que voilà beaucoup
de scènes ont été filmées par les
journalistes les manifestants pendant
précisément ces manifestations de gilet
jaune le samedi selon vous où guillaume
martin est ce qu'il est pas normal
finalement on democracy de pouvoir
contrôler demander des comptes à un
agent public
je crois que c'est absolument
fondamental de pouvoir contrôler
l'exercice de l'ordre dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions les policiers qui agit
sur les terrains du maintien d'ordre des
manifestations
et puis on l'a vu ces dernières années
ça n'est pas une question théorique
c'est une question a été centrale il ya
un problème dans la gestion du maintien
d'ordre de manifestation il ya des
violences aussi d'écouter un certain
nombre de manifestants c'est une chose
on peut pas dire qu'ils ne soient pas
qu'ils ne fassent pas l'objet d'une
attention particulière de la part des
pouvoirs publics
et je crois que les citoyens peuvent
doivent également pouvoir contrôler en
tout cas avoir pouvoir se fixer leur
propre opinion sur la façon dont les
choses se déroulent en manifestation du
côté des forces de police et je
comprends mal l'inquiétude des des
policiers à 7,7
ce besoin de clarté sur la façon dont
les choses se déroulent en manifestation
guillaume martin qui prend on comprend
mal l'inquiétude des policiers qu'est ce
que vous voulez répondait d'abord
répondre que effectivement la police
rendez compte
et d'ailleurs libre à chacun de saisir
les autorités compétentes ce parce que
la police est une des plus contrôlés au
monde
des dispositions sont prises puisque
vous avez la plateforme igpn fait saisir
le défenseur des droits vous pouvez
aussi filmer les policiers en
intervention
donc ya pas de débat de ce côté là
l'inquiétude elle est que les policiers
lorsque des vidéos sans fait est que les
visages sont diffusées lorsqu'ils sont
reconnues lent dans l'espace dans la
sphère familiale
eh bien il
on souvent attaqués nous avons des cas
de plus en plus récent de policiers qui
sont reconnues qui sont agressés
notamment quand ils rentrent à leur
domicile
nous avons eu aussi des cas par le passé
tout aussi dramatique avec des
fonctionnaires de police qui ont été
clairement identifiés rappelez-vous de
magnanville rappelez-vous de honey
rappelez vous également de notre
collègue à lyon il ya quelques mois
c'était au mois de juin qui s'est fait
agressé par plusieurs individus qui a
terminé sur un lit d'hôpital
donc je crois que il faut arrêter
d'hystériser en fait le débat sur cet
article 24 de la loi il n'est pas
question d'interdire de films et
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas possible la loi
de 80 sur la liberté de la presse est
extrêmement clair sur le sujet nous ce
que l'on demande c'est juste qu'il y ait
une attention particulière pour que la
sécurité pour que l'intégrité physique
et psychique des policiers soient
préservés et je crois qu'il faut pas
oublier que derrière l'uniforme il ya
des hommes des femmes des pères de
famille et surtout des enfants qui
souvent subissent indirectement je
dirais l'exercice professionnel du
métier
et justement vous disais n'est pas
question de ne plus filmer
vous avez dans le sens de gérald
darmanin cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale qui tentent d'être rassurant
écouter le ministre de l'intérieur est
ce que les journalistes pourront
continuer à filmer la réponse est oui
pourront-ils continuer à diffuser la
réponse est oui
est ce qu'un citoyen pour un film une
intervention de police la réponse est
oui
pourra t-il dénoncé au procureur de la
république
la réponse est oui mais pour un tour
désormais faire des appels ou vient le
temps des policières pour un taux faire
des appels au meurtre sur des policiers
pourra t'on demandé que leurs femmes
leurs enfants eux mêmes lorsqu'ils ont
un supermarché lorsqu'ils rentrent chez
eux comme ces policiers de magnanville
crottés gorge et égorgé madame la
députée devant l'enfant de six ans parce
qu'on les a retenus
alors non et tant mieux car tic 24 soit
adopté guillaume martin votre réaction
le ministre de l'intérieur vous un petit
peu convaincu je ne mens pas je crois
que le ministre intérieur confond qui
cite l'exemple de magnanville alors
qu'ils ont de manobi ne correspond pas
du tout à l'objectif qui est fixé par
cette loi
à quoi elle dit que toutes les images
qui serait diffusé avec une intention
malveillante l'image de policiers en
intervention serait réprimée par la loi
alors évidemment on vous dit ce n'est
pas interdite diffusée il est pas
interdit ce film et c'est l'addition
c'est au delà de ce qui est écrit dans
la loi castrais les conséquences
la façon dont elle serait utilisée le
fait est qu'il ya aujourd'hui unanimité
et de la profession des journalistes
chez les avocats chez le défenseur des
droits des rapporteurs au conseil des
droits de l'homme de l'onu etc etc qui
tous aujourd'hui disent qu'il ya un
effet il y aura un effet pervers de
cette a7 à cette loi et on vous dit oui
c'est pour protéger les policiers
d'abord je suis un peu étonné parce que
ce sujet des policiers qui seraient
traqués chez eux après les images qui
serait diffusée sur internet est un
sujet nouveau dont on n'entendait jamais
parlé avant première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que tout à
l'heure votre interlocuteur s'est trahi
lui-même avant même de parler de
policier qui seraient traqués qu'ils
seraient victimes de diffusion de
l'image de leur image sur internet
il a parlé de la police bachir est le
problème il est là le problème c'est
qu'il ya une fraction aujourd'hui du
corps policier qui l'a nommé pas que
l'on exposé à la vue de tous des
pratiques qui pour certaines d'entre
elles sont plus que discutables et même
sans doute illégal donc je crois que
aujourd'hui au vous posez la question
faut-il choisir entre la sécurité et la
liberté
je pense que ce sont des choses qui
s'oppose pas et puis il faut de voir de
quoi on parle enfin de sécurité je ne
suis pas certain que la sécurité des
policiers soient comment dire ne puisse
pas être garantie aujourd'hui le meut le
1er mai le ministre de l'intérieur dit
une chose qui est fausse lorsqu'il
laisse entendre que aujourd'hui le la
loi ne permettrait pas de lutter contre
ceux qui appelleraient au viol qui a
perdu aux meurtres de policiers
et tout ça est prévue par le code pénal
tout ça est prévue par le code pénal
pourquoi ajouter une infraction donc on
sait en réalité que l'effet pervers
ça serait que les faits ne serait pas
une meilleure protection des policiers
mais dont on sait par contre que l'effet
pervers serait en réalité de limiter la
diffusion et même le fait de filmer des
comportement discutable des forces de
police aux demandes de leurs commandes
des opérations de maintenance je pense
que ce texte est très dangereux c'est
pas pour rien qu'ils
unanimité contre contre lui et je
voudrais dire la chose c'est que ces
derniers mois à plusieurs textes ont été
alors pas forcément toujours sur les
mêmes sujets mais ont tous suivi la même
tendance qui tient à la réduction des
droits et des libertés
c'est et dansant dans des contextes et
sur des sujets différents la wag elle a
été sanctionnée par le conseil
constitutionnel parce que le loi parce
que l'europarlementaire majorité à
l'assemblée nationale n'ont pas voulu
entendre les avis et les critiques
étaient formulées contre cette loi ça a
été le chaos également sur la loi contre
les fins de peine des terroristes les
aux parlementaires gouvernement n'a pas
voulu entendre les critiques étaient
portées contre ce texte il a été
entièrement sur les parcs conseil
constitutionnel je le dis aujourd'hui
j'espère que si ce texte devait être
adoptée il sera porté à la connaissance
et à l'examen rigoureux du conseil
constitutionnel et je ne doute pas que
la conclusion à laquelle il ya un tel
qu'on s'est constitué c'est une nouvelle
fois de dire en réalité ce texte est pas
conforme à nos principes essentiels à
nos principes constitutionnels ou groupe
majoritaire devrait entendre cela à sa
naissance de donges en revient à la
question initiale effectivement en
liberté ou sécurité faut-il désormais
choisir ça pourrait être un sujet de
philosophie du bac vous comprenez tout
de même cette inquiétude ne vaut pas vos
détracteurs avoué les détracteurs de
cette loi c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'affaires on les cite souvent en
exemple à faire je souviens même
finalement la sphère georges fred aux
états unis qui n'auraient pas été
révélée sans ce type de vidéos est ce
que ça vous le concéder trop de même
absolument pas puisque d'ailleurs c'est
c'est bien vous me demandiez la perche
jusque dans l'article 24 de la loi il
est très clairement spécifié que si vous
êtes détenteur de vidéos qui permettent
de faire la lumière sur ce que vous
supposez être une action de police qui
serait pas dans la cadre réglementaire
nom d anthologie co qui tomberait sous
le coup au pénal vous avez tout le
loisir de transmettre ces vidéos à
l'autorité judiciaire et l'autorité
administrative
je ne vois pas où est le problème dans à
la fois le fait de filmer de recueillir
des vidéos et de les diffuser à
l'autorité judiciaire et enfin mettre
vous vous êtes trompés parce que vous
avez parlé de diffuser les interventions
de police mais ça vous pouvez diffuser
les intentions plessis a pas de débat
l'article de loi ne disent pas ça
l'article il dit diffusé le visage des
policiers ou tout élément permettant de
les identifier
c'est en ce que le police bashing et
l'or et que les policiers sont souvent
traquer jusqu'à leur domicile
c'est en cela aussi que les policiers
sont obligés de déménager quand parfois
ils subissent une controverse des
accusations parce que vous savez m
souvent les condamnations se font sur
les réseaux sociaux et non pas dans les
prétoires et c'est bien regrettable
parce que vous qui êtes attachés au
droit vous savez très bien que il faut
l'argument de la défense
il faut aussi l'argument du ministère
public et il faut aussi au milieu quand
même à garantir un peu je dirais la
sécurité physique et mentale de ces
policiers qui je le rappelle prennent
des risques je le rappelle sont vingt
blessés par jour à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
et je crois que l'heure est assez grave
pour qu'on ne mette pas de l'huile sur
le feu je crois que cette loi ne va pas
aussi loin que vous le dites
elle n'est pas liberticide elle ne porte
pas atteinte à la loi de la presse à la
loi de 80 et tout le monde aura le
loisir encore une fois je le dis de
filmer des policiers en intervention
le modem a séduit il est possible de
porter des recours etc et que c'est en
définitive à l'autorité judiciaire de
trancher le fait l'oeuf était que
l'ensemble des procédures sur les
centaines de plaintes ont été saisi
l'igpn l'appui pas moi vous tirez aucune
procédure contentons autant on sait et
les images et on le sait parce que les
images son public elle ne le serait sans
doute pas avec l'adoption de cette loi
on sait qu'il y à un sujet de violences
policières et qui ne sont pas toujours
qui n'aboutissent pas toujours à des
poursuites et il ya un vrai sujet
s'agissant de s'agissant du
fonctionnement de l'igpn
par ailleurs une dernière chose cette
loi est dit c'est la diffusion avec
l'intention de nuire
quelle est la définition de cette
intention de nuire
on parle encore une fois de sécurité je
crois qu'il faut aussi parler de
sécurité juridique
est ce que les français avec ce texte
seront lorsqu'ils diffusent une image si
la diffuse avec une intention de nuire
ou pas qu'est ce qu'une intention de
nuire
c'est dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec
la parution allaiter mon ancien
d'assister je pense que c'est
extrêmement grave c'est un vrai sujet et
je crois que ces deux là dessus que
j'alerte et compris le hall low vernon
et je suis pas le seul nombreux sont le
fait religieux que le conseil de l'ordre
du barreau de paris vient de prendre une
notion aujourd'hui qui va dans ce sens
et il y attention ce texte ce texte est
pris dans la précipitation
surtout ce texte il est pris pour
satisfaire une fraction du corps
policier mais il ne répond pas aux
exigences constitutionnelles qui
régissent encore aujourd'hui un autre
droit
merci à tous les deux guillaume martin
stanislas godon d'avoir été avec nous
pour débattre de cette loi qui est
examiné à partir d'aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale merci à vous